I wrote the best intentions out of the
low points
in American UN relations and immediate
period after Iraq and so forth,
and that things are better than they
were.
I also think the UN has gotten
marginalized in a lot of ways and
partially because of the Bush
administration,
uh,
I think we sent an ambassador there,
John Bolton,
who was very hostile to the institution
that reduced America's own role,
the Air America zone.
Standing there.
We also had the chief hand in choosing
the Secretary General Ban Ki Moon,
now ban Ki Moon is not quite two years
into his five year term.
And it is possible that he will prove to
be a more forceful figure than he has so
far.
But certainly the impression one gets is
that the United States chose them
because they thought he would be an
inoffensive pro-american figure.
And that's what he's been.
He's been an inoffensive pro American
figure.
But if we actually want the UN to
matter,
then we have to choose it's chief
executive for his competence,
not for his harmlessness.
Uh,
and so it's just troubling that we have
not sought to use this institution in
the way that it can be used.
And I would hope that Obama,
we'll take it more seriously.